please i'll be crying i'll be begging my
mom please let's go
bro oh my days mommy that's when you use
our mummy mummy mummy please mommy
[Music]
you probably know this because you know
about alcohol but i never knew this okay
apparently so obviously you know tequila
um
apparently not apparently but my brother
told me that like in mexico they don't
really [ __ ] with tequila like that
okay because
no it's not that they don't [ __ ] with
tequila but they don't like the hype
that tequila has okay because i never
knew this like tequila obviously comes
from like agave yeah
and tequila is just agave that grows in
the tequila region of mexico
so there are other agave-based
liquors
they're exactly like tequila
but they're not called tequila they're
called other [ __ ] did not from wherever
they're from did not know that um one of
them's actually um
called flipping my brother told me
because it's
um
a spider
yes that brings a bell but i don't know
from bleach my g
um it's a region in mexico okay and they
have their own agave and they grow their
make their own
[ __ ] tequila
and it's called a spider no way my
brother's got a butler at home
and i was like so that's just tequila
but from my spiders yeah i was like bro
i don't understand what you're telling
me here
so mexico they don't they don't care
about tequila it doesn't matter to them
because everything is everything is
killer yeah yeah yeah and else because
of a different region yeah
yeah yeah
mad i never knew that it's mad in it i
never knew that it was interesting that
is very interesting espada denman are
pissed though because tequila is
worldwide tequila is the thing
the thing i never knew that yeah and it
can't be called a tequila unless it's
from the agave grows in the tequila
region does it's not any better than any
other
same with champagne i was just thinking
that same champagne champagne and this
is from champagne you can't call it
champagne champagne that's called one
i call it fearless
yeah prosecco whatever that's crazy i
never knew that yeah i honestly never
knew that yeah bro actually i was so
intrigued when he told me that i was
thinking [ __ ]
i had no idea
um
and also
this is cool as well this is this goes
as a testament to like um
like how japanese people don't [ __ ]
around when it comes to like
not honor but just their pride in their
[ __ ] in their craft so um one guy that i
just
fighting the kid brendan from fire and
the kid is doing his own whiskey okay
and it's like 50 bourbon mixed with 50
japanese
okay um and that's his his whiskey okay
and um
yeah 50 bourbon 50 japanese but the
japanese
whiskey makers like the distillery that
he uses they wouldn't let him have
anything that hadn't been aged for 10
years okay in these like specific
barrels
um
and obviously he was just like now i've
come like it's cool i just want the
japanese whiskey tastes fine and they
were like big man
you're not having it unless it's been
aged for 10 years i'm telling you that
now
so if
we're low on stock because we're still
aging then that's just your business
oh man you're not going around there
calling it japanese whiskey if unless
it's been aged for 10 years mad
i love that i love that i heard that i
was thinking gang yeah man gang these
japanese bros don't [ __ ] around they got
pride in their work firm not nine and a
half years
ten ten minimum
so yeah i was guessed when i heard that
asking that's sick okay i've never had
japanese whiskey i have um it's closer
to scotch i think than the other types i
couldn't tell i think i couldn't tell
you i listened to a whole podcast one
time about different whiskies
and um like the meaning so did you know
i think i might have told you this
before like the e so you know how some
people spell whiskey without the e e y
[Music]
um
apparently if the england if if the
england if the [ __ ] country
that the whiskey comes from has an e in
the name of that country then it's spelt
e y if it doesn't have an e in it it's
it's not spelled that way no way yeah i
never knew that so america spells it e y
um irish whiskey spars it why why
scott
spells it why i think um
no way
japan must spell it y yeah i think
that's what it is it's the e in the in
the name of the country
bonkers yeah it doesn't make sense does
it
i mean it makes sense not necessarily
make sense now but i can understand it
better yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's wild that is wild and then you
never think about obviously you should
think about it but like like i said with
the tequila thing you just sometimes you
don't even think about like kentucky
bourbon that has to come from kentucky
and you're like but kentucky's some
small poxy little [ __ ] state like
they take pride in their [ __ ] bro they
all
bourbon is
i think it's one of the biggest
wholesalers in like america in terms of
bourbon in period yeah it must be bro
it might [ __ ] about when it comes to
like you said with the japan thing and
all of that yeah yeah yeah
that's wild mum it is it's interesting i
liked it um yeah i don't know what i was
i was on holiday when i listened to that
podcast a whole podcast about whiskey i
don't even like whiskey that much i do
like it but i found the whole thing
interesting
when you tap into something that
you have on like a regular basis like
whiskey for example you have it like
once every couple weeks or whatever
and you start finding out more and more
[ __ ] about a specific subject you think
damn this makes you appreciate it much
more it makes you appreciate much more
in thinking oh my day so this is why
this is this and this is why this is
that and it's just like okay i've
learned something today yeah that's the
thing today like um
like i'm desperate to try this spider
thing now i'm desperate to try it where
did you get it from your brother um i
think he might have bought it back from
mexico when he went to he went traveling
around there yeah yeah yeah i think yes
you might boil back from there because
i've not seen anything like that in ends
like in england manipur
it's a whole it's a cover-up it's satin
no one knows about it espada
nah man
tequila
as a region must be they're caked
they're cakes because if anyone from a
different country ain't no one like even
that's a dread thing so like say if we
want to start our own tequila company
like we're not gonna be the ones
who live outside mexico to try and
convince everyone that it's the same
shit's tequila
we're not going to do that yeah we're
going to go to tequila big man we need
your thing in it yeah just pattern us
yeah i can't be bothered with the pilot
thing these mother hunter don't get it
it's too hard to sell let's just get
tequila yeah exactly and they know
that's the they they know that's the
thing i [ __ ] i never knew that bro hmm
i don't know but i don't know what the
drink is called
obviously you've got tequila got a
spider you've got whatever other regions
they've got what's the drink called i
know what you mean what's the drink
called i'm just it's tequila when you
[ __ ] ferment agave what's it called
i need to know tequila what what is it
just says tequila on it
let me [ __ ] fight we got to get a
bottle in here
what does it say on there tequila 100
from agave that's all it says yeah
it doesn't say what it's actually called
which is an agave drink
um
pajamas tequila is crafted
from the highest quality 100
weeba blue agave which is carefully
harvested closely trimmed and slowly
steam baked in small brick ovens
the cooked agave is then crushed
fermented and twice distilled in a small
batch
using the time-honored tohono process
and one of and one of the more modern
roller mill methods to create patrons
silver smooth taste
but that means nothing to me so it's
just like i said fermented agave
that can't be what the drink is called
fermented distilled agave or patron
tequilas are distilled at bot and
bottled at hacienda patron in the
highlands of
i'm assuming it's called jalisco but
it's got a j at the front so i'm
assuming salisco mexico
um yeah it doesn't say what it's
actually fair play but
on that note on that let's do one
that was a good one i'm actually happy
about that
i always get a bit nervous
yeah man that was a good one that was
good i was good my teeth are gleaming
now yes
um
fun fact of the day today guys
so
for those that aren't interested in
football i'm gonna give you a little
background
um you obviously know who lana messi is
lionel messi is one of
if not one of the greatest footballers
of all time um that's alive right now
and he was at barcelona all his life and
he currently
or more recently rather went from
barcelona to psg and this was a big deal
for the footballing world because he's
always been in barcelona
and barcelona wanted him to stay
he wanted to stay but the fees and blah
blah blah he's worth a lot they couldn't
afford it they couldn't afford him
basically long story short
so i think his final press conference or
like
quote unquote like exit interview um
from barcelona he was he was crying
and there was a tissue that he was using
apparently this tissue is now on auction
for a million dollars
because they said that they want to try
and make who never know potentially use
the genes or whatever from that tissue
to try and [ __ ]
what's going to make create an
artificial lean or messy in the future
it's so it's west bro
some people have too much money too much
money they're allowed to have two fam
who's got oh
who's got the time to sit there and
think that's a good idea
let me buy this for a million a million
a million it's on auction for a million
dollars that's ridiculous who knows
where this tissue is yeah yeah
what evidence did they have that they
must he must have filmed he must have
filmed
messi putting it in the bin or something
like that feeling himself picking it up
and taking it you you need evidence
evidence
evidence bro that's mad that's a good
point that you brought up the football
team
because obviously as you know i wanted
to because we never talk about football
on here yeah and you ride or die
football and i haven't watched football
since i was like big man ting 16 oh man
properly yeah yeah properly obviously i
watch my new games yeah sometimes
ad hoc mainly when i'm either with you
or with like other friends and stuff but
um i haven't known any i've
intentionally stayed as far away from
football as i could
um so you can explain some [ __ ] to me
okay and we can keep this going okay all
right talk to me so i know nothing about
donnie this is interesting because i
know nothing about my man just like how
no no no no no um just how like you know
sometimes nothing about certain
basketball players and stuff yeah yeah
yeah yeah i know nothing about grealish
okay nothing okay and then obviously
this deal is the talk of the town yeah
yeah yeah yeah talk me through the whole
thing so i can only know i'm gonna uh
i'm only going to go off what like
obviously i know i don't follow greenish
that much but he was basically he's been
at the village his whole life i think he
was there since he was like 15.
i every time i watch um jack greenish i
always say he's the hot he's got the
hardest working cards in england have
you seen these cars castle wham jack
greetings
hardest working cars in england bro his
cars are massive they are they are they
are um he's been aston villa his whole
life he was been the talisman throughout
the whole what these last few years or
whatever but he was been injured blah
blah blah
and then he went to the euros um he
didn't he i don't think he started one
game at the euros but every time he came
on
the world went mad for him yats love him
mandem love him like he's he's just a
talk at a time
[Music]
yeah
yeah i wouldn't say it's a young baby
beckham let me know let me not go that
far because beckham is on a different
way beckham was and still is on a date
yeah yeah so let me not compare this to
you don't play the same position any of
that but
um jack relish is
for i don't know why but he's he's the
pride of england at the moment okay cool
granted he didn't score anything in the
euros but people just love his energy
and love his aura and love what he's
about about football purely because he
was very dedicated to his club um he was
there for
i don't know my 10 12 years aston villa
he was there since the kid
and then obviously the euros happened he
had a few good games and stuff even
though he didn't score and then he got
the he's the highest chance he's got the
highest transfer fee in
uk football i believe it was 100 million
from aston villa to manchester city
um funnily enough i saw him he came into
he came into my spot
um i think the week before their first
game okay and the whole team so i saw
them it was cool it was joel that he had
to do some
he had to do some [ __ ]
written like ritual
initiation type thing that was singing
it was jokes it was jokes um then
he
i think he came on
their first game was an away game they
played tottenham and they lost i think
he was a sub i don't know if he started
but he they played the first home game
uh this weekend just gone or last
weekend
um he scored he scored the second goal
but it was one of it wasn't like
like he did like a mad thing and then
yeah like a massive like sign it was
more of the ball just hit when he went
into the net yeah but it was his home
debut
he scored a goal they won the game five
nil like it was a good feeling
okay but jack relish is he is
when he gets the ball you just know
something's going to come from it you
feel comfortable you feel comfortable
when you've got the ball yeah yeah
you know he's going to attract people
towards him that will free up the space
for other people okay he will either
pass the ball to you or he will get the
foul to create the free kick yeah never
to be score a goal yeah you know so
that's the reason why i say one he's the
hardest he's got the hardest one cops in
england because he also for two or three
seasons running he was the most fouled
player ever
yeah and this was obviously whilst he
was aston villa but so people know his
potential that's why so many people are
drawn towards him that's right that's
the reason why
he creates so much because opportunity
two or three people are going to be
drawn towards him or looking at him and
then just freeze up all the other man
that's the reason why he's a great guy
that's 100 million i feel like a lot
don't get me wrong
100 m's yeah
when when they when that transfer
went down asked them villa gas like
asthma 11. i don't think obviously no
team has received 100 million in england
before because that's that was the um
the highest transaction fee
but for a team like aston villa you know
if he was like united
or united
united to chelsea
they can afford that blah blah or they
they can still do a good with that
whereas aston villa getting a hundred
mil
from man city for one guy yeah gang yeah
yeah take him take him take him even
though stadium tour exactly
that is new stadium tour you can use so
much with hundred m's yeah hundred m's
yeah yeah yeah that's too much money in
football there's too much money for one
don new stadium talk nah too much money
there's too much money in football bro
so yeah man it's um it was a big deal
for him it's a great i feel like it's a
great move for him purely because
he's never won to my knowledge i don't
know he's never won a trophy
um he could have won like an fa or
something i don't know like back in the
day
but he's obviously never won the premier
league he's never been
part of the champions league or you
wrote like all those kind of things so
this move for him is is fantastic that's
heavy that's fantastic that's heavy i
like that especially because he is the
pride and joy of england yeah yeah or
these past few months like sterling and
all that man pride and joy of england at
the moment so i'm very happy for him
even though he plays for the op just
yeah yeah but sometimes in fort worth
you just gotta appreciate what you've
got i love it you know that's that's why
i love football that's live man i like
[ __ ] like that it's cool mum i like that
i like you like that um
there's some not similar but like
there's a few there's a bit of
basketball news going on in the minute
like in terms of there's a two two
situations like in terms of the pride
and in terms of like the money and stuff
like that so the opposite things
happened in the nba okay um
do you know about dennis schroeder
dennis schroeder no cool
so my man is um
he is where is he from i think he's a
german national okay um plays in the nba
playstation lakers okay
this is his first season starting i
believe so uh first season starting just
gone season just gone on his first
season starting did okay
lakers wanted to keep him
they often so basically just understand
he's any man he's any guy he's not even
like in the first five he's just started
this year is the first year he's ever
been in the first five but he's been on
the laker roster he's been he's been
playing the game let's just say that
let's just say he's been playing the
game it's the first year he's ever been
starting five right wow um lakers were
happy to keep him for another year
um no they were they wanted him for a
four-year deal they offered him 82
million across four years
um
and he's any guy he's any guy 82 million
82.05 20 mil a year they offered him
um
he said nah i'm gonna try my luck as a
free agent basically okay and um
yeah try my luck as a free agent and see
how the market cleans me up he's got
obviously he's gassed
he had an okay season and he's gassed
fam
talk to me
what went wrong it didn't go well
no one gave a [ __ ] about him now he's
signed with
the
uh i've already forgotten i think it's
the celtics somewhere [ __ ] cold i
know that yeah i think he's gone to the
celtics and they offered him a one-year
deal
for
eight million i think
obviously in context of basketball that
isn't that's not a lot of money but for
the average joe for the average show
eight million just so just so yeah just
a bit of context
but
for the fact that you had a four year
contract and you were guaranteed 20 mil
every year
so now you've got a one-year contract
for eight
downsides bro
you have to move to cold ass boston out
of lavish la
for more for less than half of what you
were you were guaranteed in la
and now it's a one that's that's the
thing
the bad thing it's a one year deal
one year deal so they've paid you eight
mil
for one year
for the fact that they've paid you eight
mil
watson ain't no punk team either so the
fact that they paid you eight mill they
they don't even care if you play or not
they've given you a busted contract for
one year you're not even going to get
any court time
you're not going to get enough court
time to get a better deal next year yeah
yeah you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ]
damn and this is your first year off the
bench and they promised you four lavish
years
i was like nah let me take my child let
me take my chances i think i'm i'm a bad
[ __ ] so as he said so in the season
just gone he was he did well this year
he did okay this year okay yeah not well
he did enough for the lakers to think
he's worth another four years and where
was he before the lakers or he's been in
there i can't remember to be that's once
he's any guy i don't follow him i've
never followed his career but he's been
delayed
he's comfortable with the lakers um and
then yeah this was his first proper
season off the bench playing as a
regular starter if i recognize his face
because obviously i watch basketball
i wouldn't be surprised if he didn't
recognize his face what's his name
dennis schroeder dennis schroeder the
name does bring you back sc h
image it is um i think it is boston he's
moved to yeah yeah no
i know his face i know his face yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah fam
so yeah he's done now so that's the
thing that's the thing as well as like
that's the bad thing the one-year
contract is the scary part the one-year
contract and the low payment i would
even be concerned for him if it was a
one-year contract for 20 mil
i'd still be worried yeah because it's
just one year one year you've got to
prove it now yeah and you clearly the
season just gone you clearly didn't
prove it enough for anyone to want you
yeah so you know you need a much better
season than the season you've just had
with the lakers
and you're probably not even gonna be
starting in boston you are [ __ ] good
luck from now that's all i'm saying good
luck from now damn eva gets six man of
the year
and
[ __ ] smashes it and becomes the next
james harden yeah always done
it's long for him
that's tough man it's tough it's doggy
dog it is doggy dog
follow me up i know we're talking a lot
about sports but obviously
a few months ago there was this um esl
the
european super league
do you remember yes that whole
i didn't look into the specifics i had a
i had someone tell me like a brief
overview um but yeah like i i i
understood it at the time so
just for context what it was at the time
was
they wanted to make
fifa i.e the football association in the
in across europe the same thing like
america in terms of basketball in their
league so in the nba no one gets
promoted or demoted like you stay in the
same league season yeah and that's what
they want to do for football yeah across
what five different countries so england
spain italy france and
i think germany backed out i think was
somewhere else
but obviously united backed out chelsea
backed out city backed out i think psg
backed out there were so many teams that
backed out but i'm thinking why on earth
how does that promote
any form of competition they wanted the
same team to be playing the same
quote-unquote champions league well
there wouldn't have been any champions
league because that's out of fifa now
they wouldn't have been
able to qualify for the world cup
because that's part of fifa they
wouldn't have been able to qualify for f
like there are so many things that were
so wrong with it but it was more of a
powerhouse hungry thing for the the
bosses and the owners to just make more
p
yeah and
it made me wonder i made me think like
why doesn't that happen in america in
terms of just having a a relegation
system like if you're [ __ ] big man give
the give the the d league for example
the the chance and the opportunity to
[ __ ] progress if you're
if your number you'll feel stuff that if
your team is the number one seed of the
season in the d league surely you've
you've earned the right to be in the nba
man it's true you know um
it is true i think
it's because i think the reason is is
because
teams are so there's so fewer players
on an nba court
that typically if a team is doing well
it's like crushing it
so if someone for example was crushing
it in the d league
it's because of one person
typically
and instead of promoting the whole team
they'll just take that person yeah but
then that's what happened with uh what's
his face
uh we'll talk about the other day uh
uh plays for
the bucks
um janice no no not not not janice he's
the second guy uh
m
middleton middleton yeah he was in the d
league okay i think okay i'm fairly
certain he came up from through the d
league i
i remember them talking about someone it
was either him or was either due holiday
it was one of them yeah
but yes continue i do remember fairly
certain
because i watched a little
little uh piece on him about just like
never giving up on all this [ __ ] so i'm
pretty sure i might be wrong but i'm
fairly certain he came up through the d
league um
and
yeah so
i think with basketball that's the
difference
is that
in football it's very rare that you can
just
pin success down to one person well you
never can you can never if you've had a
[ __ ] unbelievable season obviously
you get players that are like
yeah yeah but you can't ever say they
were purely successful because of this
person whereas in the nba in basketball
even you can yeah 100 it happens all the
time and that's why people get taken
here there and everyone that's why
they're trying to create super teams
because now even if you've got two or
three if you've got three all-stars on
one team all of a sudden now it's a
super team yeah if you have that in
football it's like you're still you're
right yeah like you're decent yeah we
expect you to have at least three yeah
if you've got less than three superstars
then psg for example psg now have messi
bappe killian and bappe and um neymar
yeah yeah but apparently i think
umbape wants to leave because he doesn't
want to play with mercy or name one of
them want to leave because they don't
want to play with messi and the reason
why messi used to play for barcelona
when
not sorry not messy sorry
neymar used to play for barcelona whilst
messi was at barcelona the reason why he
left barcelona was because he didn't
want to be in messi's shadow but then
when he went to psg he was in bape
shadow because in bappe's are [ __ ]
bored
he's a [ __ ] boy he's like 22 at the
time he was like 19 i think it's like 20
21 now maybe i'm not too sure
but
now one of them want to leave it's just
all
everyone wants to be the star man
obviously you want to be the one
bringing in the goals and bringing home
the debate of course it makes sense and
that's why i believe like you said or if
you have three three star men in a team
you have to be doing the thing so that's
why i believe thoroughly this year that
psg will win the champions league all
right okay psg they have they've got no
choice but to win the championship yeah
yeah let's play di maria and angel di
maria he's a argentinian footballer he
used to play for united that's the only
reason why i ride for him because he's
played for united in like 2016 for like
one season or two seasons
before he moved to psg
and the coach of that's the [ __ ]
fattest spider i've ever seen the same
ones last time is it the same as last
time oh my god you man if you make a
cedar spider jesus
it's just hanging that's the same
one
it's got a family in there
um
what was i saying yeah i ride for di
maria because obviously he used not
obviously but he used to play for united
and anyone that used to play for united
i'm always like yeah man you're still
you i still got connections yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
no matter what you're still gang but i
hated him um we played
we played psg this was when di maria was
at psg and united played a psg in the
champions league maybe a year and a half
ago two years ago two seasons ago we
played them home in a way
first leg we lost at united at old
trafford we lost two nil di maria scored
he grabbed the bottle like he scored in
celebration was the grab they threw like
beer bottles at him he grabbed the bowl
he was about to drink and dashed it on
the floor and he's like keep quiet keep
cutting
he's like you [ __ ]
i think two weeks later
we went we went to theirs and we beat
him 3-1 which was gang yeah yeah and i
was like yes united blah blah blah but
like i said
back to what i was going back to what i
was talking about anyway i feel like psg
will win the champions league this
season because the team that they've got
bro solid solid man there's so many
all-stars in that team and they've also
got on a free do um who did who did
england play in the finals again in
euros italy italy so the cul the
goalkeeper duma roma whatever his name
is he's at psg now big boy for free he's
a for free
they got messi they got um when gina
went out of he used to play for
liverpool he's a strong strong um cdm
and he got they got for free they've now
got um
sergio ramos used to be the captain of
real madrid psg for free and do maroon
whatever his name is the goalkeeper for
big man
with messi with a with neymar yeah with
uh verratti with
um what's his name di maria they have to
win the champions league
but i love his enthusiasm i love it i
love it i love football
but then i'm starting to think is it a
case of too many stars on one team and
they're going to crash
there has to be
everyone can't be the star you know but
i don't know we'll see we will see it's
true it's one of them ones i feel like
um from my limited knowledge i feel like
messi is old enough to not get caught up
in that [ __ ] yeah messi needs
another trophy before he dips yeah he's
nearly done out yeah yeah i feel like
obviously neymar might be a little bit
vexed still a young buck
but i feel like yeah i feel like messi's
older i hope anyway old enough and
mature enough to not fall into that
[ __ ] of like let me prove on the
best player at the cost of this this w
like big man you wanna ball have the
ball in it
you want to pull out the ball brav
i know what you mean but um
that sounds like it sounds super
interesting bro psg if you i know a lot
of people aren't into football but
it's just so
people forget that
when
when we watch football yes we watch for
entertainment and
when women a lot of women don't like
form a lot of guys don't like football
as well but people think that we watch
football because
uh
well
what's the point blah blah people forget
that
one this is their job like regardless of
our entertainment yes we watch it week
in week out we get vexed and blah blah
blah this is their job they have to
perform weak in
out secure a spot in the top 11. yeah
yeah yeah if you're not starting big man
you're not doing something right unless
you're injured you're not doing
something right did you know that
every feature like every sub or if you
start you get a bonus obviously if you
score you get a bonus everything is to
do i didn't i had no idea everything's
to do with p if you're on the pitch
you're going to actually you get extra
cake
if you score obviously you get extra
cake if you win trophies you obviously
get extra cake i knew about the trophies
thing but i didn't know about the if you
start and if you get something you get
extra i don't even found out recently
that's wild so if you're not in the
starting eleven bro it's tough and a
football team is consistent depending on
the team consists of 24 to 26 players
only 11 man can play
and with the keeper if you're the number
one keeper you're calm oh you're you're
just your place is solidified yeah
that's why this rumor guy or whatever he
is he's got the game a lot creme de la
creme he's got the is that what six six
six seven he's six seven [ __ ] tall
the key part psg's keeper i think his
name is kayla navas yeah kayla navas
he's a great goalkeeper he's been the
key before god knows how long
so i i'm a bit skeptical as how that's
gonna play out purely because he's been
doing great for them but my man is he's
a goalkeeper he's a goalkeeper and it
doesn't
for a keeper it doesn't matter whose
team you're on from
if you clear the ball save the ball
we're yours
it doesn't matter you don't need to mess
with anyone save the [ __ ] ball that's
all you need to do you've got one
[ __ ] job do it
yeah that's uh i like that i like that
passion my mind spiral sometimes when i
think about football that's gang also
again football do you not think it's
crazy or any sport it doesn't have to be
football um do you not think it's crazy
that because
we watch sport week in week out kind of
thing we just watch it as entertainment
value whatever or we watch our team as
entertainment value but let's say for
example i play for united you play for c
no let me not say c because i'm more
times probably going to face you more
than once or more than twice let's say i
play for united and you play for
southampton for example
southampton aren't likely going to get
into any cup competitions they're only
going to be in the regular regular
season so let's say for example i've
come to your yard and smacked you up
four nil
you have to wait seven months to beat me
again yeah you know it's long so you
it's that's in your head for time and
you want to get revenge you want to do
all of these things but we're watching
it week in week out as football yeah
whereas you as a player personal for me
you as a player is personal you've got
you've got to wait months to come and
meet me again and then you you these men
were chatting [ __ ] in my ear as well bro
they were trying [ __ ] to my ear bro when
the corners come in and we're just all
shoulders
and i'm gonna try and pop in my earphone
now i'm a whole 90 minutes
away games must be daunting sometimes
i remember
when we were in school
do you remember obviously playing like
when you're in school you play uh
either football i didn't play football
squad play basketball
but you would only ever play
in the local league
with the other schools we would only
ever play
one through the season one school one
time
okay so we play every school in like our
town yeah and then um there will be some
like local tournaments and stuff like
that and you might play some of them
again
but there was
at least one player on every school team
that you had to be wary of oh and it
just created so much you didn't want to
because if you lose them you ain't
playing again until next year yeah
you weren't playing again until next
year bro he used to piss me off so i
remember so this is mad i actually
remember this so okay we had um um
this is wild as well because so we had
obviously my team
and then we had um
another team
called hatton so they're called uh sucks
they the name of the school's like chris
so christopher han anyway i don't know
who the [ __ ] that is but anyway um they
on their team they had these two twins
called kane and lewis they weren't that
big but they were [ __ ] tall
and then they had my boy jason on there
so hat was the tall team
patton was the [ __ ] tour team because
all three of them [ __ ] were
tall as hell and my team was short we
had one of the shortest teams
so we had um
hatton which were they were ballers yeah
because they had them three yeah
wrestling couldn't name a single other
player on their team
three step three them three were running
and gunning
so newt was hard when we played them i
was stressed but i was just when played
everyone then we had another team called
ren who were like our closest school in
terms of like proximity and stuff like
that
they weren't okay cool so they weren't
they had one guy called richard
tall as [ __ ]
played he was a baller as well two white
bowlers
he had the fundamentals down to a team
fundamentals he went about showboating
he was had the fundamentals bro
so we had hit they had him the rest of
the team was kind of trash but the the
thing with the their team ren they're a
rugby school okay and they're
they're just militant yeah like it
didn't matter that they didn't they
couldn't play ball yeah basketball they
just were just so dedicated to winning
this game that they were willing to do
their best and they knew richard was
there well i call him higgins this is
everyone called higgins higgins was
their top don yeah so they had to run
him as soon as they're running the ball
is long for everyone yeah yeah so i
remember we had to face off against him
so every time we face
the three big boys that we have to worry
about it's kind of like high q fam yeah
i was literally thinking you man yeah
i'm literally thinking about haiku so
this is the thing jesus you go for all
these schools but you never think about
yourself yeah yeah so you go through in
um
hatton we had the three big ballers they
were stressful to deal with um but they
were kind of team if you could get them
frustrated they would [ __ ] up because
they're
they're
they're show boaters yeah they want a
[ __ ] and fame that's what them three
men wanted [ __ ] and fame so they
they wanted the dub in the flashiest way
possible of course so you could beat
them if you played them if you played
them against their weakness which was
their showboating you could beat them
easily because they were selfish and
they want [ __ ] and fame yeah yeah and
they'll get frustrated they get
frustrated and [ __ ] up yeah that's how
we used to beat them
ren um militant players but they only
had hicken so basically it didn't matter
how militant they could be you could
outscore them they were the kind of team
that if you were gonna go coast to coast
like one for one one for one one for one
we had more good players than they did
yeah so we would beat them if we're
willing to go back up back up okay as
soon as higgins is off the courts we're
going up by 15. yeah yeah yeah as soon
as he takes a break if they start them
off as soon as he gets a break we're
going up by 10 15. straight off the bat
because the rest team is trash but soon
as he comes back in it's game time
um so that him big tall guy really good
player fundamentals would never [ __ ] up
ever
um then we had
um another team called williston now
wooleston they were a short team like us
but their point guard um
was a guy called johnny yates
baller in school baller
baller white guy baller handles and
could shoot his dad was a coach okay so
he they would have him and his little
brother both from [ __ ] ballers okay
his little brother came to our school
and he was like four years younger than
us he was playing like
three teams three years older than he
was playing for the teams like his year
the year above and the year about that
no way he was a baller both of them
bawlers bro so every time we went to
waterston you knew it was long yeah
because johnny's gonna have you up bro
and he will snap your ankles if you ever
give him the chance
stress but you knew it was a fun game
yeah because as good as he was
he's not tall so you can lock him down
if you need to how tall was he roughly
oh he was like
school so obviously we were shorter but
now he's probably like my height or a
bit shorter okay
so
in school he was just a normal height
guy not sure but he was a normal height
guy yeah yeah yeah probably and school
yeah in school he was probably a little
bit shorter than me um but he was a
hooper
he could hope control he didn't want to
guard him yeah but i wanted to guard him
yeah because i was thinking i'm taking
down johnny like the competition yeah
but it was that was our favorite games
to play against dead man nice because
i knew it was just it was like me and my
boy john would always argue like who's
taking johnny who's taking johnny and
then i'll be like i'll [ __ ] defend
johnny i don't care i don't care i want
that that victory do you know what i
mean yeah um so
we'd uh we'll play against johnny and
that was the most fun team because their
guys were okay he was the big boy
um but they had no tall guys on their
team um until year ten but i'll get back
onto that okay
no you're eleven you're eleven yeah yeah
eleven all the time yeah
but yeah it was us versus them and
sometimes they would be uh sometimes we
would beat them we were very evenly
matched but he was their
guy he was that guy he could do anything
but he just wasn't taught if he was tall
he would have been like a much better
version of higgins and it would have
been impossible yeah yeah yeah we would
never be able to lock him down yeah yeah
but um yeah that was fun and then the
rest of the teams were just [ __ ]
like no offense to them but we had
another team called rawns another team
called high inferiors another team
called something something they're all
[ __ ]
um but those three
teams they were the ones so they were
like the seed and you were like just
underneath them as a team um so that's
what i thought
but it actually was never like that so i
remember basically i never thought this
is why i said you never think about
yourself i never thought about that and
then johnny from wooleston
coincidentally lived down the road from
me and i never knew that well he lived
like two streets away from me and i
never knew that and one day i was
walking to the
court by myself just bouncing my ball
and i walked past his house and he was
outside playing a hoop in and i was like
swear you live here because williston is
like
far mm-hmm um and i was like oh you live
here like yeah i live here and stuff
like that so we started playing
and then we started talking and
basically i had we had the same
discussion that mean you're having right
now like oh when you play hat and you've
got this and that then he's like yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then he said like and
when we play you you've got you and john
and i was like oh what do you mean and
he's like yeah like when we play like my
school was called weavers in it when we
played james and john um james john like
james and john that's like
stressed about james yeah yeah when you
were playing weavers you know we were in
the basket like all right james and john
you gotta watch out because me and him
used to play we didn't give a [ __ ] about
the rest of the team me and him were so
competitive but like in a good way yeah
so you know what i said about the
messier neymar thing yeah if one of if
they can get mature enough yeah big body
mm-hmm but if they're vex about who's
the best of course then they'll never
work yeah yeah yeah but me and him
were
like i was so competitive i liked to
intentionally pretend like i thought i
was [ __ ] than him okay because i
remember we we we used to train and then
every year our coach would award us like
either mvp or mip most improved
and he'll give us jerseys
and two years in a row he got mvp and i
got mip but secretly i liked it i used
to pretend like i was vex but secretly i
liked it because i think i'm getting
better big mac and the next time i want
to smack you up so me and him play to
get against each other because you could
tell he wanted that glory yeah i didn't
really care about being the best yeah if
anything i didn't want that pressure
yeah true if anything i didn't want that
pressure i wanted to be the guy coming
up through i wanted to be the guy who
was like look the [ __ ] out for him true
like he's the he's the enemy you want to
be but you want to be the
underdog
everyone's like this guy i can't stop
him but like this is the main guy but
they've also got this guy as well so me
and him me and john john used to play
fam play
passing everything just
it was live
it was like the fast breaks yeah it was
long
it was long so when i say what you
thought we were in the like kind of
lower scene and stuff like that it was
actually kind of all even okay everyone
would win some everyone would lose some
of course um but it's weird that i never
once thought that me and him were like
those guys so just like in haiku
where like they're stressed about the
big boys on every other team
but the other teams are secretly
stressed about these moments
yeah yeah fyi guys sorry to cut you off
to high q for those i don't know is an
anime about volleyball just to give you
clarification bro yeah yeah jump on high
q it's like so many people hate sport
anime i was one of them live i was one
of them
but that's the thing so yeah we were
those guys the guys that thought that
everyone else was so much better than us
but
when they were coming to play us we
never knew that they were whispering
like big man when we get there they've
got james and john you need to do
something about them because if one of
them gets free it's long yeah yeah yeah
so you need to lock them both down we
used a hoop gang who was so much fun
back then it was so much fun back then
it was so much fun back then
[ __ ] i miss it i know you do bro [ __ ] i
miss it i know you i missed it so much i
was thinking
oh i just want to play ball um i just
miss it um but anyway
i've got you said you wanna sorry to cut
you off again you said we're gonna go
back to
year eleven times zero year 11.
quincy
quincy he got traded
so williston picked up they had a new
starter yeah um i don't know if he
always went to that school and never
played or he just had them or maybe had
a massive growth sort this [ __ ] was six
ten
six foot ten through half i've never
seen anyone that high tallest guy i've
ever seen in person seen anyone that's
what six foot ten mike scene is six
seven yeah
well huge
quincy was huge so he they put him on
johnny's he he went to johnny's school
yeah so they for i think just for year
11 he played for uh williston
wow 6 10. yeah bro you couldn't do
anything he used to just dunk it betty
jump of course you should just
go to that and it was in
well
there's nothing we could do
but then we played a tournament one time
and i twangled him he dunked on me in it
this is a separate tournament this is a
sixth form tournament okay so he went to
their sixth form i went to my school
sixth form so for fun we would just play
we used to play we both used to play for
county anyway and we play on the same
team and stuff and um
we'd see each other a lot we were
friends so we see each other a lot but
we never used to play against each other
until they had this local like six form
tournament whereas like r6 form versus
loads of other six forms but no six one
was a serious borders so i wasn't really
worried about it it was more for me it
was like fun yeah like i didn't have
john anymore because he went to college
somewhere he went to an art college i
think um
so i didn't have him anymore but for me
it was just like it's whatever it is
yeah yeah yeah just to get some cardio
in
um so there's one i think games will
think i'm going to practice this so i'm
going to try this with mine because it's
just trash and then um
no respect bro when i was like prime
hooping days i had no respect for anyone
um and literally only cared about if
you're not playing for like england i
don't care about you yeah
so yeah i used to we played it and i
played him and then out of nowhere bro
they just had this play they just i
wasn't paying attention they just dashed
in the ball
jammed it in my face bro balls just all
up in my cheeks
nuts everywhere from nah
and now i was just there on the floor
like ah
did he jump well as soon as he landed
you just looked down at it bam you hung
on a thing and just stared at me come on
and then did that slow jog back just
staring at me on the floor this is
literally high q when you look when they
do the the set a dump yeah
like here you're just looking at he
looks down at them
he joked back i was like
i told these man i so i sold
i told daddy run me the ball now i
called him out that's how little i cared
about this tournament i called him out
he was down in his heart i was up at my
lou yeah i said come
told all these boys oh my boys i said
everyone get down there you come now i'm
not i'm not having this guard me i dare
you phil i dare you to guard me twangled
his feet are yeah because he was so tall
he couldn't yeah this is the biggest
move there of course so just
yeah a little shoulder shimmy here and
there yeah round about bam i dazzled him
all the way down to the other court
quick little uh
fake yeah pop fan reverse layup under
his finger and just like sharp man get
away from me
get off me it wasn't impressive was
dunking on him but but you got yeah i
got my redemption yeah yeah of course
you needed that yeah everybody yeah you
can't get dunked on balls right now not
redeem yourself you can't nuts in my
mouth just like oh god kill me now
kill me now hold on home turf it was and
i'll caught his house it was at our
school
[ __ ] just kill me bro um you heard her
what would you do ting no yeah um
where's my phone [ __ ] arm i've been
talking about sports for ages i forgot
about that right
my in-law said what would you do right
my in-laws were visiting and i couldn't
be honest entertaining them so i had to
so i told everyone i fancied a nap
because of a headache i went upstairs
and watched some spicy porn for a solid
20 minutes despite not being able to get
the sound to work on my phone
upon returning downstairs i could see
everyone awkwardly looking at my
headphones only for my partner
i already know what's happened only for
my partner to inform me
they could all hear the sounds blaring
out of them as i didn't turn the turn my
bluetooth off nobody looked impressed
bro what do you do
what do you do bro
i actually don't know i rick the thing
is i already know what i'm gonna do if
if i'm watching porn and i can't hear
[ __ ] and i've tried multiple videos
something's obviously off you know i'm
not gonna stay there for 20 minutes
listen to audioless porn big man who
watches porn for 20 minutes by the way
that's a long time he's watching it like
his leisure he's watching it like
watch it like that episode nah
bro
if i can't hear anything there's clearly
something wrong i need to figure it out
yeah because i need to hear i need i
can't just watch it i need everything
involved you know
so clearly something's wrong let me
figure it out he was he was jumped out
he just wanted to whack quite out as as
immediately as he could you know but
anyway what would you do you've walked
downstairs
you've mastered you're not you've got
your girl your girls parents
let's say a couple nephews and nephews
there's chilling what do you do
who's yard am i in you're in her yard
you're in her yard it's like my girl's
yard your girl's yard but you you are
staying over for the night
you got like your bose headphones just
chilling there audio connected to your
laptop upstairs
and you know both headphones they're
when they're not on your ear
they're just loud when they're
screeching bro oh my god what do you do
what do you do
this is the first time i've been
absolutely speechless i can picture
myself there so let me let me think
about it so
i'll go downstairs
everyone's staring at me
i can imagine coming downstairs
i'm playing it off as if you've just
come back from it out like
fam
crusty but
what's up
what are them ones but they've heard the
whole thing
that's double embarrassment
so there's someone addressing me
because at this point i don't know
what's going on is someone saying what
happened let's
okay no no all right let's just say
let's say
sorry let's just say
your girl's mom as soon as you walk down
the stairs you do your whole
stretch whatever fake nonsense you're
everyone's staring at you like what and
then your girl's mom just picks up the
headphones they're just
and i know now you know i know
immediately you get this
and you're like
now what do you do
you know immediately because as soon as
you see the headphase you think no
wonder my [ __ ] audio wasn't working
you put two and two yeah immediately i'm
not dumb
immediately
um
i'll say yeah i did i'd
i'll be so mortified my i can already
feel my blood running cold in my veins
i think i'm like yeah thank you and then
i would kiss my girl in the chicken i'll
just walk out
i'd have to walk out i couldn't look
back there's nothing i could
i wouldn't have the strength through
having i wouldn't have the strength to
be like oh god uh yeah yeah sorry
i wouldn't have the strength for it i'll
quit
bro there will be so many questions they
can ask themselves because i'm not going
to be there
20 minutes why is he watching port when
one first of all when the whole family's
here does he have an addiction
that's what they think does he do this
often fam does he have an addiction
is that a family gathering in someone
else's house and he runs upstairs to
much porn does he have an addiction
what's wrong with him
i'll leave my relationship for that a
man said i'm going upstairs for a cheeky
nap
he bust one out and lied about it
came up with this whole
this whole facade nah fam i would
happily lose my relationship for that
happily if i'm a young buck as well in
my teens
100 i'm losing my relationship to that
embarrassing you know she's telling all
to get a hundred percent i have to move
town everything
if we've got mutual friends oh i'm very
excited mum please let's go
mom please let's go to another city i
don't have to explain it but please i
can't explain it to you bro we have to
leave we have to get out now i don't
want to hear questions
get your [ __ ] let's go please i'll be
crying i'll be begging my mom please
let's go
bro oh my days mommy that's when you use
our mummy mummy mummy please
mommy i can't remember the last time
when my mummy oh fam i don't remember
that's hilarious i remember the day i
stopped i told you i remember that
daddy yeah yeah yeah
he said he was he imagines pause
[Laughter]
i was so scared that's too funny oh i've
recently started calling my dad pops i
call him pops like monotonously now i
don't call him dad or anything anymore i
don't know why i just spiraled out
nowhere this is normal now yeah i called
my dad uh
what do you mean bro call my dad
yeah we call him park
um i don't think you've necessarily told
me that before but i think you've said
it in like conversation oh right yeah
yeah
yeah but yeah i i have to take an
emergency exit i don't know what else to
do i just don't have it in me to just to
firm that bro that's embarrassing james
it's it's too embarrassing it's
embarrassing james 20 minutes like you
said there's just too many questions to
answer yeah there are too many questions
why here why now why for so long
like what's wrong with you
why do you feel the urge to do it now
if you were so bored like why don't you
go home like
is this what you do when you're bored
you just sat down with porn like did you
even fap like what what was it [ __ ] what
was that you were just watching it bro
oh my god
like what do you have to and then the
parents are not going to be happy no
they're going to say what do you what do
you have to say to sarah
i feel like sarah's owned an apology
what do you have to say to sarah family
do you have to say for yourself
no one can say that to me no one could
put the earnest on me yeah like james
what what do you have to say for
yourself
oh escape escape i don't care anymore
you mean i don't care
bye i'm not dealing with this you know
embarrassed i am i'd have to be honest
do you know how embarrassed i am i'm
leaving
sarah i'm sorry
i'm [ __ ] sorry i'm sure you can
understand yeah
if the she was at the other foot you did
100 everyone's out what'd you do
um
i would
i would be shell-shocked obviously but i
think
i don't know i don't think i would have
i would
be able to stomach the questions
i genuinely don't think i'll be able to
stomach the questions
but within the same breath i don't know
how to exit the building
because i understand the fact that it
will be a fight or flight situation
where you're like i can't deal with this
i just need to bounce but i generally
don't know how to do it you know because
my girl's parents are at the yard for a
reason let's say it's
i know you said we're at my girl's
yard right my girl's parents here i
suppose yeah so i wouldn't know
i just wouldn't know how i'd leave the
situation obviously me and the girl are
meant to be together we'll probably go
in there to visit the parents blah blah
we probably came together
you know
so it's like yeah this whole thing in my
head i assumed that
it was her and her parents yard and i
was a visitor if we came together
no
i'll climb up my own [ __ ]
bro
i don't know man it's um it's west
i would i would like to say i'd want to
leave
but i just don't know how i'd go about
it i honestly don't know how i'd go
about it
because i'd be too
i don't i can't have that many eyes on
me especially for that kind of situation
i can't have that many eyes on me i
wouldn't know what to do i don't know
what to say
i will not i'll be so scared
to receive a message from her bro if i
see her if i see sarah's name pop up on
my imessage on my whatsapp i'm not open
i'm not opening it
i'm not opening it bro you've been there
a message from a certain someone because
of whatever and the sooner you pop up i
feel sick i just feel sick
oh why why wouldn't this all just go
away what i literally want
i want the world to swallow me i want a
black hole i think i would just have to
assume an alias and be like my name is
james and i'm a sex addict
i've been seeing therapists for years
i'm sorry i needed a quick fix
now you know i'm glad if anything i'm
glad it's out yeah if anything i'm glad
we all know now that's a persona you
have to keep up with lie
i would lie i would tell my girl the
truth when we get home yeah yeah yeah
when we get in the car and she's like
what the [ __ ]
man
you knew what it was i'm like
what am i supposed to do you know what
i'm like man said did i take the a45 or
the m2
what option did i have i had to leave i
had to go upstairs [ __ ] combo i wasn't
tired oh and nothing else to do oh my
days that's hilarious that is hilarious
oh jesus i'm glad i see that fam
question hit me
tell me the truth though god no it's not
even that bad but just tell me the truth
okay okay i hate when you say tell me
the truth
i hate it it puts me on edge
am i too old to start skateboarding
that's very random
um
before i answer the question
where is this interest come from
i don't know
well
i've always been interested in
skateboarding okay i've never had the
urge to go out and try and do it have
you ever owned a skateboard yeah when i
was a kid yeah same when i was a family
when i was a kid i owned a skateboard
and
i got up to the top of i lived next to a
park that had a [ __ ] massive hill
and like a footpath on the hill
so before i could learn to skate
i sit on it and roll down the hill
and then just lean side to side sat on
it made it halfway down the hill fell
off skidded fam
knuckles bust up knees bust up
everything i was just on the grass like
that
i never use the skateboard again after
that and you see the skateboard just
peel off it's just like nothing so i'm
just there just twangled
so i knew i was never going to step on
the skateboard again
but then do you remember when they had
those mini skateboards yes the long thin
ones yeah yeah yeah i had i had one of
those and i used to like do little
tricks
in my living room and [ __ ] and i was
like this is cool
um i've always been interested but i've
never ever had the urge to like go out
and do it
and then i was just i was um
i followed nigel houston on instagram i
don't know
big boys skateboarder okay probably like
the most famous skateboarder okay in
america um
and
like the tony hawks of this day yeah
basically
and um i also followed this paying
female skateboard
called skateboard skateboarder she's
brazilian she's called
oh
i want it's like
oh what is her name sorry i'm gonna have
to figure it out i can't i can't let
that one slide
it is
something buffoony or something like
that
leticia buffoni
marie priya
and she's sick
she was in london the other day actually
but um
she's live and i just watched their
stories and [ __ ] yeah and i think [ __ ]
skateboarding is cool cool and i saw a
tick tock the other day where one guy
was like um
oh
uh started skateboarding a year ago
today big man as well started
skateboarding a year ago today um and
this is the progress progress these are
tricks i can do and he did them and
obviously yeah he looked like a like a
deer on ice basically yeah yeah yeah but
at the same time i was like he landed
all of them yeah yeah and i was like
fair play
that's pretty [ __ ] cool and just as
like a cool
is this just a cool way to get from a to
b yeah i'm more saying like i wish i
need to go on more walks and stuff like
that and if i just had a skateboard or
wanting to try skateboarding i would
have a reason to go out more
and just and do [ __ ]
and like i was also thinking about
obviously
your boy
your boy basically dresses like a
skateboarder anyway i remember you
saying this i never wear trousers
i'm always wearing baggy tops now yeah i
wear the [ __ ] classic reeboks yeah
and i had some vans on yesterday
and i was like and i also want to get a
tattle on my neck okay
like
how like i don't know okay bro i don't
know i want a half sleeve on my leg and
i want to tap it on my neck sick i i
just want the neck one i do like i do
like the idea of it it doesn't need to
be like extreme but i need a
you can't do another job interview
tattoo
that's what i need now that i've quit i
need to solidify the fact that i can't
go back i can't go back into the doggy
yeah yeah
yeah you can't do another job at the
view
hilarious i neither you can't get hired
tattooed that's what i'm after that's
what i'm in the market for yeah so if
any are you guys a tattoo designer or
whatever designers and you have some
designs or some ideas for some cool neck
tattoos let me know um
and i also want like a half sleeve on my
leg so from like here to here
um of like i don't know some kind of
anime collage kind of thing that'll be
sev i think you'll be sick but i don't
want
like your typical face of a character on
here okay i want it to means i want it
to be something okay i want to be some
kind of story where only true anime fans
will even know that that's an anime
tattoo do you know what i mean i want
that kind of [ __ ]
so i want something like that but uh i'm
not entirely sure what yet
that's cool man i need to go rough i do
though yeah um but the next one i ain't
got a [ __ ] clue i want not a [ __ ]
clue
but i definitely i definitely want to
take it on my neck just so you can't get
hired anymore that's what i want you
can't get hired anymore and you have to
be okay with that because you took this
step and now you're going to live in it
forever
but that's what i want so and i thought
man that just makes me look more like a
skateboarder so if i if i had all that
[ __ ] yeah and i dressed that way and
actually was good at skateboarding yeah
bro
it's a wrap that's just a new level to
my repertoire you know what i mean yeah
science added to the cv yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah it's a bit different so i thought
maybe i should buy a skateboard and
start trying to practice skateboarding
to answer your question i don't i
personally don't think it's ever too
late to do anything period unless like
you're disabled or something you know i
mean but
within the same breath
do you honestly think you would
keep it up i don't know i hope so that's
the that's the only thing oh i genuinely
then again
it's not like you're
there there won't be anything to keep up
in the sense of you've not got a target
like you've not got it's not like in two
years time you're trying to compete for
something or you're trying to enter some
competition yeah you just want to do it
for recreation do it for fun and
something you want to do so
if that's the
if that's where your common um goal is
at then why not yeah man you know i
might go for it i might buy a skateboard
go 3g
yeah man i just don't know if 30 is too
old
i mean i don't want to i don't know man
i don't want to rock up in the skate
park i will scan on
like this old [ __ ] it can't do nothing
you know yeah and i'm just saying like
you've got you've got no balance fam
one kick and i moved like half an inch
i'm just there oh embarrassing bro
you'll be so surprised that how many p
you'll be so surprised about how many
people would be willing to want to teach
you
you'll be surprised i say uh
i also watched a skateboard in anime
a while ago yeah yeah
yeah it's quite cool oh what was it
called it was called skate
excuse me bless you
i've got it on a list i've got my anime
list
it was called skate infinity
yeah it was all right man
fair play
so yeah i don't know man i don't need
too well bella loves skateboarding but
she doesn't skateboard but if she's like
walking to town or something like during
lockdown especially obviously everyone's
trying to do something more
extracurricular than don's near town
exactly yeah yeah you know exactly yeah
yeah when i used to live in my old spot
um every time belly used to go to town
or whatever she'd see ever if it's a
football or a skateboard she's involved
she's involved i saw and she's older
than me she's all new you know so she
would just
ask the guys it's obviously different
for a woman yeah because she's she's a
paying woman it's obviously different
but within the same breath it's never
too late bro true it just goes to show
it's never too late to do what yeah the
thing is i i i also have an obsession
with being very [ __ ] at things again
better things it was the same when i
started jiu jitsu my first day juju i
was god awful bro i love the fact that i
was completely [ __ ] at it and i was like
gang and then when you get better and
better and better and then you become
good and you can actually say oh i'm
good at this thing yeah and you're
better than i like being in a position
where you've started something and
you're absolutely [ __ ] and you get to a
point where
you are better than a hundred percent of
the people
on their first day trying this because
you know how like you can be doing stuff
for a while but people with like natural
talent towards things can come in on
their first day and smack you up yeah
and you're like oh well i've just wasted
a year my life yeah yeah because this
guy's just gifted like you can get that
in a lot of sports whereas like um
like i feel like obviously really
technical stuff like jiu jitsu and like
some martial arts and stuff like that i
like
being that guy on this first day getting
my ass handed to me and then six months
a year down the line you get to a point
where you meet someone else on the first
day and you're a million times better
than they are yeah and you're thinking
[ __ ] bro that was me yeah that was
actually me yeah yeah yeah and you think
it's so rewarding of course i just find
it so rewarding so yeah [ __ ] it you know
what i am going to get a skateboard and
i am going to jump out for plane and
you're coming too
that really we already discussed that
people keep messaging me asking them
what is happening i actually
i'm gonna scream through that i'm gonna
scream my lungs up i'm gonna be laughing
so hard i'm laughing so hard at you that
i won't have any fear in me i know until
my edges up to the end your knees will
be shaking oh bro your knees will be
shaking i'm gonna tell them just hold me
hold me like a lover hold me
wrap your legs around me do what you
need to do
bro i genuinely think i'm gonna be one
of them ones where you know when
um you see videos of them man that go on
like slingshot roller coaster rides and
they pass up mid-air
phil dunphy
you're dumping one of the roller coaster
modern family
vamp mid-air just like
and then he wakes up
and then he just drops again that's
going to be me i promise you that's
going to be me
i'll tell you now if i'm i couldn't be
there free-falling look up to my side
and just see you dangling asleep
i would
scream
fam i don't even think there's something
wrong i'll be laughing you scream you
pull the parachute hard fam
oh god i couldn't just see you there
i'll be dangling i already know it i
already know i'm gonna miss the whole
experience i'm gonna be
dangling oh my days my heart wouldn't
take it
i can't breathe
that's so funny bro
that's too funny man
[ __ ] jesus christ that's hilarious
i'm scared bro i know you are i'm very
scared i'm scared for you i'm scared for
me
but it's it's gonna bang don't worry
it's gonna i don't doubt it dude it's
gonna it's gonna be a sign to take off
the list ah i've got anomaly [ __ ]
and then we can wrap this [ __ ] up
[ __ ] me that was funny
right
this is a different kind of one hit me
i'm 23 and live with my dad uh this is a
guy by the way okay i'm 23 and i live
with my dad i work and make enough money
to live alone but due to family
circumstances i had to move back to my
dad's a few years ago and was told it
would be
me saving money as pops does all the
bills
it started out great for like three
weeks i wasn't paying for nothing i
would give pops money but as they said
it was less than i was paying living
alone
but as they say all good things come to
an end
long story short i'm paying for all
different kind of bills
my question is how do i save to move out
when i've got all these new
responsibilities which weren't part of
the original plan
any advice would be great
by the way if you didn't guess already
i'm nigerian
i feel like that makes all the
difference
um yeah because i remember a time where
um obviously i'm nigerian i remember a
time when i was living i'm back at home
with my parents and i think this is when
i had first started
maybe grill on the market maybe
um
my parents were like all right boom now
that you're making a bit of pee
you gotta chip in
standard didn't it and i was like okay
cool cool cool and obviously i told you
time ago we always used to say
yeah yeah
um
but because at that time i
didn't have any plans of saving to move
out
it was very different for me yeah i was
just frustrated i was giving my money
away yeah you know
sex that was giving you anyway yeah but
when you're like 18 19 20 21 you don't
really think
you don't really understand you know
like
i'm i felt like my i felt like my
parents felt like i was a squatter you
know yeah i have to i have to chip in
so
in his in his context or his point of
view
did you say what he did does he did he
say job twice no he didn't say
i mean it's tough because
obviously because i don't know what you
do and obviously the amount you earn and
blah blah it's hard to
say
how you can get out how you can get
yourself out of that situation i think
the best thing for me to say for you is
probably speak to your parents and say
boom i've got this plan that i want to
move out i want to try and save x amount
of money
so
i can be here in my life in two or three
years down the line i feel like if you
have an adult conversation with an
actual adult
they will see you in a different light
as opposed to you being their son or
their daughter just living in a yard and
paying money here there and everywhere
because it's inevitable that parents are
gonna
see once they once especially african
parents or nigerian parents once they
see you making
some pee and you live under their roof
you're gonna have to contribute no
matter what
no matter what you will say yeah you're
going to have to do the food shopping
yeah contribute a bit to the council tax
yeah don't buy this here by that there
and it's inevitable you know but i feel
like if you have a conversation and be
like boom i want to
in two years time i want to move out and
have my own spot because of x y and z i
feel like it would be great for me and
this that and the other
then they'll probably see you in a
different light then they'll probably
feel see that see you as an adult see
you as a person that
you're actually trying to plan at this
age you know you're actually trying to
achieve something and be better and be
more independent and all those kind of
things
but it just depends he has lived it
alone before okay
he lived alone first and then he said
because of family circumstances he had
to move back yeah and now we can't
afford to move back out again
i forgot about that i was just i was
sparring on that yeah i was sparring on
that forgot about that bit
um his dad knows all of that he don't
want to hear it yeah he don't want to
hear all this independent chat his dad
just wants to save a bit of pee
the rent is too much for him
the bills are piling up he wants to be
sweating
it was an easy life he wants the easy
life and he still wants to watch
football on the weekend
damn
you're not going anywhere he's not going
i'm sorry bro you're not going anywhere
i get everything i just said i get
everything i just said you're paying
your dad you've got itchy thumbs you're
paying rent until you get another job
bro
until you get a better job you ain't
going anywhere or get yourself a
girlfriend bro move in with her get
yourself a girlfriend with her own spot
and move in with her that's the only way
out you ain't going anywhere brother
i'm sorry nigerian or not you're not
going anywhere
oh my god you're paying rent until you
can't pay rent no more
[Laughter]
nah that's long it's an open interest
i'm swinging i'm swinging someone hit a
no one's getting me in that predicament
i'm swinging someone you're paying rent
you can't be right now my parents could
never put that pressure on me i'm
swinging them i'll murder them
which mean i used to live alone and then
i i i
acted like a responsible man and moved
back in for you and now i'm trapped and
i can never get out trapped that's it
you're done
that's it bro no sorry bro the answer is
no
this is not gonna do i will leave
i'll leave i'll live in my car until i
can find somewhere else g
i'll leave i'll say now you're taking a
piss out of me your parents will change
the locks immediately
what i need to shower what you should
afford that for you
you're you africa man when it comes to
parroting
will forever forever tickle me bro
so harsh harsh because it teaches you
how life is bro it does it just just
teaches you how like anyone can get it
yeah if you live in an african household
anyone can get it
you know
it's just a way of life
but it builds you as a person oh black
summer for real for real
[Laughter]
for real for real black summer for real
anyone anyone could get it nah i'm not
growing up like that i'm not growing up
like that i had no choice oh my god
but yeah fam that's hilarious open and
shut up no my mom was on a different
thing
never when i got my first job on stuff
for that she never asked me for no money
this is the difference this is the
difference maybe she should have asked
me for money in retrospect but then i
would have been fixed either way yeah
she might think i thought she made me
get a job yes as soon as i turned 16.
you're getting a [ __ ] job
yeah and i was like nah i don't want one
i've never wanted to
i didn't want one then i don't want one
now i've never wanted one leave me out
of it yeah and she was like bro she was
like
when i was your age
my dad never let me get a job and i
always wanted to do fun things with my
friends and i i wanted a job it wouldn't
let me get a job and all this stuff so
now you're old enough big man trust me
you need money you need to be able to go
out for your friends you need to do this
you're getting a job big man i said [ __ ]
that
i didn't say that to her face obviously
but i was like [ __ ] that bro i'd rather
sit and wake i don't care i'm not
working
you can't make me bro i'm not doing it
yeah yeah i'm not doing it if then i
want to go cinema i can't afford it it
turns out i can't afford it i'm not
getting a job i don't want to work
turns out i can't afford it
bro i'm so against having a job
but i was
i think i was more against someone
forcing me to get a job
because
it was like a lose-lose it's like not
only do i not want to be here
um at the job but at least i get paid
it's like i don't want to be at the job
i don't even want to get paid i don't
want to have anything to do with this
yeah yeah yeah like
you're making me get the job and these
men are making me stay and these men are
making me work everyone's making me do
[ __ ] i don't want to do it and then i'm
going to fight someone yeah if it was a
loser
lose yeah yeah i was even vex when i got
my first job professor was so easy yeah
it was so easy really good working at a
leisure center okay i think i said this
before i used to work at a leisure
center
and i had like one or two shifts a week
there were like three or four hour
shifts
and then when i first got the job
i used to box
my boxing club used that leisure center
as a training center and i used to play
basketball there as well so my
basketball was on the basketball court
my boxing was in the boxing gym
and um
i will spend so much time in central
center just from my extracurriculars so
when i got a job there the manager
already knew who i was
and he said look i need you for these
shifts it's like gonna be dead like
you're mostly gonna be doing cleaning
and stuff okay if you're working on a
day where you've got boxing or
basketball look just go do your training
i don't want to interrupt your training
and stuff like that and then come back
after you shift and finish after your
training and finish your shift
i was like
i did that for like six months then he
got sacked then they put a new manager
in linda [ __ ] linda
she said the first thing she said this
basketball boxing thing forget that
you're here to work
i remember you said it not too long ago
it must have not been like she is you're
here to work big man and she worked to
me bro i used to have to hide i said god
says on the hide so she thought i was
doing something because if she saw me
just allegedly strolling through she'll
put a broom in my hand
i hated her i hated that job from then
but even as a one or two shirts a week
[ __ ] hated it
hated it bro i've always hated working
always but yeah
yeah instead of like my mum being like
right you've got a job give me money it
was like i don't want your money i want
you to have money but go get a [ __ ]
job where i was like i don't want money
i don't want anything i just i just want
anything but a job i don't care like i
literally do not care plus me and my
boys used to just play football all day
anyway but they were no no no one was
going cinema leisure was free at that
time my legend was free at that time
yeah yeah yeah i wasn't like my group of
friends want the type of friends to like
oh let's go cinema let's do this let's
do that they never we wouldn't we would
never when i was a teenager we never did
[ __ ] that cost money ever we would
always just play football or basketball
or whatever like everything was free so
i couldn't even wrap my head around the
fact why why do i need money yeah
we're going to do with it
what am i going to do with it go shop no
i don't care
i don't need it
but yeah if she was like
you're 16 which means you need a job
because you need to contribute to the
house otherwise you're out i would have
i still would have been vexed but i
would have blah fine yeah yeah yeah fine
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh frustrating i
could imagine oh frustrating i hated
working so much if you had and i
remember before i came to uni i quit
obviously i knew i had to quit that job
because i was going to uni we were going
to uni in september i quit in like june
mama was so
vexed she was so much what do you mean
yeah and she's like wait i was i'm going
to uni i can't believe anybody was like
vegan you're going to meet me for four
months yeah
whatever in it
any excuse to get out of a job i'm not
working there anymore whatever mom
whatever
but yeah sorry g you're trapped you are
trump you need to tell you that enough
is enough is enough you are trump
because big man i'm on the far yeah i
would say risk i don't know i'm not
nigerian i don't know in it but i would
personally say risk it all and just tell
pops i don't want to be here anymore i
want to live i want to go back out to
where i was i've come home
like i needed to i've done what i needed
to do but now it's time for me to go
back out to the wild yeah and you're
stopping me with this how old did he say
he was he's 23 23 okay he's not that
young he's not that young man that young
he's been an adult for five years now
he's not he's lived on his own he's had
to come back and i want to go out again
just tell him pops this is how it is i
lived alone i enjoyed it i've come back
to help you i've helped you now and now
i want to go back out but i can't
because i keep having to give you money
all the time
how are we going to patent this
what would your dad say in that
situation
if i just said what you said to my word
yeah yeah at 23
boy
he probably look at me be like what do
you mean
he look at me put his glasses down what
do you mean
bro
my heart would be
the thing is as you were saying that
i was thinking there's no way i can say
what you just said to my pop really
cause i'm like i could probably
obviously say that now yeah but back in
the day i'm thinking
the thing with i think this is with
everyone in general but because i'm
nigerian i can only speak from my
background and my perspective and
because i know a lot of nigerians as
well
back in the day when i used to live in
london so the thing with africans and
nigerians right when it comes to money
and like living situations and things
like helping the parents and blah blah
blah
they don't want that to leave our four
walls you know
i'm sure like i said i'm sure that's the
same with any and everyone but i can
only speak of my context
so
for me to
my dad will probably find a way to make
me feel guilty
to
make me stay
to keep helping him out than him
agreeing to
you even if he did say yes it's fine you
can bounce he will still find a way to
make me feel guilty oh okay i just have
a feeling that's how the conversation
will power yeah like you just want the
world to know i'm broke in it that's why
you want to leave me you want everyone
out here to know that i can't pay for it
so you don't want me to live until next
week some something stupid you know
it's just not them ones so i feel like
money situations is hard man money
situation is hard especially when it's
to do with family because
you're never to be you're inevitably
gonna feel guilty and you're inevitably
gonna wanna help out as well but you
can't
always do both or you can't always feel
both i don't know my dad my dad would
my dad will find a way to make me stay
at 23 helping him out brother if i'm
making decent amount of p
i don't see him
i don't see him
giving me and i don't see myself giving
myself an out unless he gives me an out
i swear yeah so you're just living it as
long as you had to live in it i
i feel like
until i reach a breaking point or for
example like you say i get a girl when i
go and live with her and block i just
don't see an out i don't see an easy out
whatsoever oh wow that's really
interesting i don't see an easy out if
i'm in that predicament you know i don't
see an easy out
mad
i hope that kind of answers your yeah
question he's trapped you are trapped
honestly it's a god because
your dad you're trapped as soon as you
said if you haven't guessed already i'm
nigerian i can obviously um
what's empathise
all right man good luck bro let us know
how it goes um and for the rest of you
guys patreon every thursday patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs jump on if
you've enjoyed this video guys please
pump that like button please subscribe
if you're not already guys and um
comment comment man help us with the
algorithm help us reach all the little
ears and and eyes that we haven't
reached yet um if you [ __ ] with us then
uh yeah please help out guys we love you
and we will catch you over on patreon on
thursday love love love peace peace
[Music]